yes welcome to video playing mateo 02 so
we have played against before ok that's
interesting line d5 now is tricky sorry
it's not well known this idea some
people play it antibes just play it here
this is actually quite ok for black
played this myself and turn in my chest
so very very little that white can hope
for so how to do it here 93 maybe try to
increase my control over c5 so 93 now
Claire go Susan Stefan very ambitious
are not even trying to break the pin
yeah they did he's got lots of pieces on
the D farm
why not just taking what's the big deal
here okay so he does take so it seems
him it is like the idea of the devil
porn okay so 95 is an idea for 96 my
development is pretty good here so let's
see what he does Queen c7 so too should
f4 maybe
as you for is a move potentially it's
the most interesting possibility at
least I don't know it really does all
that much maybe it's just maybe just
didn't work but ok let's do it
you still has not care for them maybe it
just needs to complete retention of
material okay that move I did not think
about it makes some sense of course take
it you cannot really get temp temp
either whoo-chow if I take it Queen
takes I don't don't really have a look
there should be four back and took maybe
this one that wasn't ready the planet
maybe it isn't bad
yeah Bishop takes e4 looks very normal
maybe then would be seven is actually
interesting immediately now that is an
interesting move f7 is hanging end to
the bishop is hanging port eggs as
always the capture in 96 that is so
that's okay we needed to do something
aggressive so so it basically says that
my concept works it cannot be like
immediately refuted but that doesn't
mean necessarily that I'm better really
not 93 is a problem and I pieces don't
don't do to a great job here in a Knight
c3 and F was hanging I don't like the
idea to take this but maybe after maybe
after not too happy about it we did it
but had to do how to make a pragmatic
decision here ok here I mean looking at
this porn and maybe a book c1 next idea
knight c6 oh well it's actually true I
didn't I didn't think about that we
should be three there is deformed
I notice squares yeah I do their squares
yeah that's pretty awful
okay now he takes it yeah that is of
course just trying to swindle now my
money good move probably i give the
chick here but maybe this one at least
maybe i have the chickens and stuff on
c8 may not really but have to base your
hope on something okay yeah I have this
check where it doesn't do much okay
like take here create something that
would be cool I wait hooks is six
actually if he goes King edge a does
look c6 ok here i can check and i still
have that idea check not extremely lucky
oh my god ma'am maybe a swindle him ok
King f6 could be playing for loss really
know a display for loss African 56k
check game wrong that was very lucky
very lucky just blunder the four-piece
them yeah interesting interesting
opening opening realm phase here I
wanted to open it up with c3 and
computer approves basically would be one
and now see form i played 95 spoon and
maybe seaforth actually the more forcing
move there like this and and then 95 I
have a couple of things here this this
the engine gives some compensation
should push that actually push the
button compensation them now your key
code Queen c7 but that also was
interesting ok the engine wants to take
on the fire
it's also interesting of course it
evaluates it as equal the castles gets a
cold-blooded move it Jesus the engines
variation and it duo 000 okay so that
was the improvement I think over bishop
and four yeah I think this is actually
something I should've probably thought
about tv5 longer because he I have to
take it is not good yet and that was of
course blundering here versus blundering
yeah remarkable yeah I just didn't see
that the bishop is out of squares him
okay again here he has to improve our
Bishop e2 is actually good at covering
covering this yet such an amazing
amazing yeah Bishop e2 is better and
sometimes sometimes we have reluctant to
take material in a position that looks
winning because we already have an extra
piece that he it's not about the
material gain it's about covering the
crucial square now he have just lost I
was very lucky girl okay nice thanks for
watching